what is a personal brand for a time I
thought it was something as trivial as
the number of followers you have on
social media
or the number of people that know who
you are or the amount of attention
that's on you at any given time but the
more I thought about it and the more I
realized how wrong I was a personal
brand is simply you is how people
perceive you what they remember about
you the reputation that you've built
your brand exists whether you want it to
or not
it's built from the very first moment
you interact with someone else
the very first impression they have of
you their experience of you so what
happens when your reputation is built
around being a toxic individual the
villain of the story what happens when
the thing people remember the most about
you is the unpleasant experience they
have with you of all the people I wanted
to make this video on that was one
person that stood out the most to me an
individual that I had personally seen do
something incredible with their
reputation
Tyler Stein camp otherwise known as
Tyler one is a well known player of the
popular online video game League of
Legends as well as a streamer on the
live streaming platform twitch.tv when I
was first introduced to him like many
others at the time I saw an individual
who was well known for his toxic
behavior and again
and then things changed Tyler one
changed his entire brand on what he was
known for from a player that was
disliked by the very company of the
video game he played tell her what's not
really that much of a personality though
I respect you is it nobody person
someone that file as a gamer
his only marketable skills being an
[ __ ] to be featured at their biggest
events in front of tens of thousands to
owning a clothing brand a protein
supplement and other collectible items
dedicated to his brand to amassing
millions of dollars in revenue
throughout his career averaging almost
twenty thousand live concurrent viewers
per stream with a huge following on his
YouTube and Twitter accounts of being
well-loved by the very community that at
first wanted him gone or some may see as
a chain of lucky events and persistence
I see is an almost seamlessly executed
rebranding of an individual a must I'm
not the first to be talking about his
story and achievements I wanted to take
a deeper dive into Tyler as a brand and
as a person and identify exactly how
someone could have changed their entire
reputation from most toxic to most loved
from a villain to a hero all in the span
of just two years
[Music]
[Music]
less wind the clocks back to early 2016
the streaming platform twitch.tv was
enjoying another year of growth in
popularity
aided by Amazon's acquisition of the
company in 2014 the platform reached a
total of 2.2 million unique streamers
that entire year there was a platform
that allowed anyone with a computer and
a stable internet connection to stream
themselves playing video games for
random viewers to come and watch live
and what to some may sound like an
incredibly niche community a streaming
industry was bustling with individuals
who are working as full-time streamers
and earning huge paychecks at the end of
the month
thanks to advertisements sponsorship
deals but mostly the donations of
viewers tuning in to watch the stream
dollars dude the front page of the site
would often present you with categories
of different games to watch people
stream and one of the most popular games
to stream at the time was the
multiplayer online battle arena game
League of Legends created by the company
Riot Games in this period of early 2016
a search of the username lul Tyler won
would have presented you with the
following streamer
Tylar one most likely had a viewership
that didn't surpass fifty at any given
time this is a small sum when placed in
comparison to other streamers on the
platform it would have upwards of tens
of thousands of viewers per stream Tyler
won or Tyler Stein camp as he is
actually named which stream himself
playing the popular video game League of
Legends in the dorm room of his
university his configuration mimicked
that of most streamers on the platform
on one section of the screen he would
have his webcam recording his face and
reactions Welton Nutt more tax extreme
na the other dominant part of the screen
was attributed to the video game itself
to put it simply League of Legends
functioned as follows two teams of five
players would be placed on the opposite
ends of a map in their base the
objective of the game is to destroy the
enemy's Nexus an object positioned in
the basis of both teams each player on
the team plays their own unique
character or champions as they are
otherwise named which are pre-selected
before the game starts and each champion
has their own playstyle and often a
position on the map that is best suited
to their abilities the average game in
League of Legends is expected to last 35
minutes the game also featured a ranking
system allowing players to climb up the
ranks and prove their skills amongst
other players of a similar skill level
so why is any of that important
[Music]
you see Tyler one was an incredibly high
skilled player who was at the top of his
game he would often be much alongside
other highly skilled and popular players
in the game but these players didn't
recognize Tyler for his ability they
recognized him for his behavior
Tyler was well known for playing one
particular character in the game named
Draven whereas typically you were
expected to play a selection of
champions and maintain some versatility
Tyler would only play during them and if
he didn't get to play Draven or if he
didn't like a particular player on his
team he would often intentionally run at
the enemy team giving them kills gold
and experience all valuable assets that
would place his opponents at a greater
advantage of winning if you were on
Tyler's team during these matches the
game would be made considerably less
enjoyable
not to mention Tyler had a habit of
insulting or demoralizing his teammates
that would often decrease the morale
with the players on his team fight this
video over and over and over and over
again Jonna was [ __ ] toxic at work
Riot Games had already banned several of
Tyler's accounts on the game in the past
but this didn't stop him from creating
new accounts and continuing to play
needless to say
Tyler's brand was built on being someone
toxic and although highly skilled if you
did anything that he didn't like your
experience with him would likely be an
unpleasant one on camera his appearance
often remained unchanged partially clean
shaven head always sporting a tank top
often wearing a pair of logitech
headphones he wouldn't speak a whole lot
on stream either mostly focusing on the
game making occasional comments and
interacting with live viewers that would
send messages which appeared in the chat
room to the right of the stream yo come
watch League man thanks a follow dude
appreciate this welcome to the number
one toxic stream in a world that and
although Tyler had built somewhat of an
inside reputation amongst other high
skilled players he remained fairly in
the dark he was just one streamer and
one player amongst millions in a heavily
saturated market right about now you
would have already formed your first
impressions of Tyler and whilst his
on-camera
in game tough-guy attitude piqued the
interest of a small audience his overall
personality probably didn't strike you
as anything special he was just a 20 21
year old university student studying
computer science who also played for his
University's football team he just so
happened to have an obsession with an
online video game that he would stream
himself playing in between classes it's
hard to know exactly what Tyler thought
at the time but chances are he saw
himself graduating in a few years maybe
starting a career relative to his degree
maybe taken a career in American
football more seriously but most likely
just waiting to see what happens next
league of legends of streaming were just
one aspect of what seemed like a fairly
ordinary life but in March and April of
2016 a series of events would change
Tyler ones future career life and brand
forever
[Music]
League of Legends was an incredibly
popular video game by all means with
reportedly 100 million monthly active
users in the year of 2016 alone it's
filled with its own personalities
celebrities and culture league as it's
often shortened to has had an immense
influence over the growing eSports
industry generating crowds of up to tens
of thousands and millions more online to
watch tournaments played by professional
players there was no shortage of content
creators for the game and one such
creator went by the name of disco heat a
YouTube channel well-known for a popular
series titled League of children which
featured toxic an aggressive League of
Legends players that would stream
themselves playing the game he actually
just gave me cancer
unbeknownst to these streamers disco he
would often take particularly egregious
moments and highlights from their stream
and upload it to his channel these
videos would be watched by others in the
community that would laugh at or mock
the featured individuals for their
behavior on the 9th of March 2016
disco he uploaded a new video to the
series titled League of children high
elo afk the video showcased a player
with a partially clean shaven head a
tank top and a pair of logitech
headphones over his head
what made this particular much
interesting was the fact that Tyler won
was playing with a well-known
professional player in the game
hi deulim otherwise known as c9 hi c9
being the abbreviated form of the
professional team he played for cloud
nine
this match was a particularly bad one
for Tyler he made numerous mistakes
during the early parts of the game and
these further aggravated him as he
started getting angrier and angrier at
his teammates this was met with a
retaliation from hi who messaged Tyler
in the game saying quote play the game
stop raging thanks to which Tyler
responded with quote at bash you IRL so
stop typing the heated exchange between
the two continued until Tyler grew fed
up with the game and typed in the chat
to his team quote dorm on fire sauce and
proceeded to remain stood still at his
base in the game leaving his teammates
to continue playing a now full vs. 5
match making it considerably harder for
his teammates to win these actions were
of course against the Community
Guidelines and would often result in
players getting their accounts banned
because of it his team eventually
surrendered the game and the video
concluded with Tyler 1 adding hi to his
int list a list that was stored on a
notepad file on his computer containing
the names of players he disliked in the
game next to highs name he wrote quote
trash kit this video received a large
amount of attention at the time and to
date the video stands at over 1 million
views this newfound attention raised the
community's awareness of Tyler won on a
much greater scale than previously seen
before new viewers began to pour into
the stream wanting to see Tyler's toxic
personality for themselves
[Music]
Tyler would gain an audience of mostly
three different types of people those
that thought it was funny to watch this
angry guy rage at his teammates if
things didn't go his way
those that rallied behind Tyler as he
represented somewhat of a rebellious
side to the community and those that
dislike Tyler and hated the fact that
someone was getting attention for being
a toxic player and promoting a
particular kind of behavior that makes
the game unenjoyable for others these
three types of audiences would often
clash on his stream occasionally
donating money with a message that would
appear on stream and be read out by an
AI voice for Tyler to hear glad you're
getting all these donations and follows
men do your funny afk
you sir are hated because you don't let
people walk all over you the leaf
community is a bunch of keyboard
warriors here's to you goods I just
wanted to say that you're a cancerous
degenerative li2 is only good for a
laughing yet it isn't hard to imagine
that this sudden newly found audience
and source of income placed Tyler in a
peculiar position the streaming industry
was saturated but this would have been a
potential opening in the market for him
to carve his own career from it but
whilst he had gained attention much of
it came for all the wrong reasons
it is at this point where I believe
Tyler made his first attempt to change
his reputation and brand in the
community in one particular highlight
from his stream Tyler announced over the
underscore from the matrix soundtrack
that he would be reforming from now on
and consequently his behavior was going
to change what is now reform a few days
later Tyler released a video to his
youtube channel titled Draven hyped from
montage featuring the same speech about
reforming he had made a few days ago
along with a montage of clips showcasing
impressive gameplay on his part
this was seen as an iconic video of
Tyler won and today it remains the most
popular video on his channel with six
million views there was also an early
indication of Tyler's ability to craft a
narrative around his brand and create
something meaningful from just one word
reformed a word that he would
continuously begin to associate with his
brand and what
he stood for but Tyler's attempts at
reforming were not long-lived the
problem was that Tyler's temper and
toxic behavior whilst playing the game
could not be subdued and roughly a week
after announcing he was reformed after
being demoted from one of the top ranks
of the game Tyler
announces on stream that he is going
back to being toxic right games gonna
tell me how to play the Tribunal for me
it's another play I'm toxic
I'm Tyler one-eyed stay in that way
let's go sure Tyler had gained a
viewership of thousands in a relatively
short period of time but his brand his
reputation what others saw in him was an
angry toxic player that whilst fun to
watch would make the game hard for
anyone else that didn't see eye to eye
with him and whilst Tyler basked in his
newfound infamy and controversial
personality amongst the community the
looming enemy was growing in the
background one threatened to end his
fame as Swift as it had come
players like Tyler won were a big
problem for riot games League of Legends
relied on teammates working together if
a single one of those teammates decided
to intentionally throw a game it would
make the experience for all other
players considerably unpleasant riot
solution to these players would usually
be banning their accounts something that
they had done to Tyler on numerous
occasions but now that Tyler was gaining
a level of infamy it was in many ways
glorifying his toxic conduct and sending
signals to other players in the
community that despite Tyler's in-game
actions he could still be relatively
successful not only this but Tyler one
was spawning copycats of himself players
who would only pick Draven in their
games and if they didn't get what they
wanted they would intentionally give
their enemy team an advantage but the
pressure on Riot Games to act would grow
significantly during that month of April
2016 some of the biggest voices against
Tyler's brand were professional players
that were more established in the
community than Tyler himself one
particular example in that month of
April saw the professional player
William Hartman more commonly known as
meteos who at the time played for the
professional team cloud9 criticized
Tyler's behavior while streaming doesn't
matter he's not funny meteos his
comments were later uploaded as a
YouTube video and posted to the official
League of Legends subreddit a post that
quickly grew to the front page of the
subreddit the majority of the comments
on this post seemed to agree with meteos
his overall frustration they saw Tyler
as a problem some even accounting
stories on what it was like playing with
Tyler one himself or his copycats
another popular voice against Tyler was
Riot Games his very own employee David
Turley otherwise known as riot freak a
caster for professional league of
legends matches during his own stream he
made the following comments about tile
I'm sad that like someone that vile is
making so much money off the game now
his only marketable skills being an
[ __ ] play
Tyler's popularity is infamy the brand
he had built for himself it was a
ticking time bomb and the more others
heard about him the more the voices
against Tyler want grew in that single
month of April Tyler ones YouTube
channel reportedly hit 50,000
subscribers and more impressively his
twitch channel went from five thousand
seven hundred followers to over 90,000
in two months Tyler had gone from a
university student who just so happened
to play league of legends to being
brandished with the title of the most
toxic player in North America with a
sudden influx of viewers on his stream
as well as money fame and money even on
a small scale have the potential to
blind a person from the truth
amassed it's unclear how much Tyler
earned from his streams during those two
months
it isn't far-fetched to assume that it
was a figure in the thousands he was
enjoying the new potential path in his
life a career as a streamer playing a
game that he was obsessed with and
despite Tyler's initial attempts at
claiming he was reformed his reputation
had already been set in stone amongst
the community simply claiming that he
was reformed wouldn't be enough to
redeem the actions of a player that had
consistently shown himself to be a toxic
individual disco heats video had spawned
a villain in the community and whilst
for some it was fun to be a fan of a
villain - Riot Games it was an issue
until finally Riot Games took action and
the ticking time bomb that was Tyler's
brand was about to face its biggest bro
on the 30th of April 2016 Riot Games
employee Raya Socrates made a post to
the official League of Legends forum
board titled the indefinite banning of
Tyla wand it reads quote heyo
instant feedback catches the most
unsportsmanlike players in league for
some go out of their way to continue
ruining games for the community because
of a well documented history of account
bans for verbal abuse intentional
feeding as well as account sharing /
purchasing invasion of sportsmanship
systems and player harassment we will
not allow Tyler 1 to hold a league of
Legends account indefinitely any account
definitively used by him will be banned
immediately upon identification we know
we're not perfect and this dragged on
too long but we want you to know what a
rare player comes along who's a genuine
jerk we've still got your back this type
of punishment from Riot Games was
incredibly rare to see where as a band
on an individual's account meant that
they could simply create another this on
the other hand was known as an
indefinite band sometimes referred to as
an ID ban it meant that any evidence of
an account being owned by the punished
individual would be met with a ban even
if that account had not broken the
community guidelines of the game it was
Riot Games essentially exiling someone
from their game the news of Tyler's
indefinite ban was posted to the League
of Legends subreddit garnering so much
attention that he appeared on our /all
pages of Reddit where some of the top
posts from the entire site are featured
this meant the news of his band had gone
beyond the scope of the league community
and could now be seen through the eyes
of strangers that had no affiliation
with the game or Tyler won during the
time of this post Tyler won was live
streaming himself playing a game of
League of Legends with a viewership
count to the tune of thousands and
potentially tens of thousands unaware of
what was happening he continued playing
the game until after it was finished he
was left to discover that the account he
was just playing on had been banned but
suddenly another wave of realization hit
as Tyler discovered the news about his
indefinite band live in front of his
viewers
boys you know what this means
[Music]
please know what this means our here
the band meant that he could no longer
stream the game that had made him
popular in the first place it wasn't
just a ban on him playing league it was
intended to be a ban on his brand
entirely I'm gonna miss you guys I miss
you guys I am it's been fun I've had a
fun you know
a fun time treatment tea boys I have
it's been fun
sorry sorry I have I let you guys down
his answers to questions posed to him
bys donators indicated that this could
well and truly be the end of tyler one
[Music]
it would have been rather
uncharacteristic for Tyler to have given
up he had received taste of Fame and a
potentially huge source of income which
although built on the wrong foundations
there may have still been hope for him
the Streisand effect is a social
phenomenon that occurs when an attempt
to hide remove or censor information has
the unintended consequence of further
publicizing that information or in this
case Tyler won thanks to riots ban there
were new eyes on Tyler people were
waiting to watch his next actions on the
2nd of May 2016 a few days after his
indefinite ban Tyler posted a video to
his YouTube channel entitled vlog about
what happened and future plans I was
banned from legal edges primarily
forever no coming back you know how do I
feel about that men saw it coming did I
saw it coming I saw calm if if you guys
knew everything I did they were they
were nice to me I'm at a post Natalia
Tyler acknowledged the fairness of his
ban something that is cynics perhaps
were not expecting but Tyler had bigger
plans for himself and his reputation to
create a real brand for himself Tyler
needed to be known for something other
than his toxic behavior in league he
needed to highlight a different aspect
of himself
one that could eclipse the negative
associations of his current brand not
only that but Tyler would have to change
the narrative surrounding himself and
his reputation right now he was seen as
the most toxic player in North America
with a huge amount of controversy
surrounding his name in the league
community but there was one common
sentiment often accredited to Tyler his
ability to entertain disco heat had
produced other videos on toxic players
in the past but Tyler had received an
audience unlike any of his predecessors
the reasoning for this was likely due to
his ability to keep viewers entertained
by his tough-guy attitude and overly
confident antics
Tyler needed to create a Redemption arc
for his brand the toxic player that
changed his ways and became known for
something much bigger than just being a
league of Legends player his initial
attempts at claiming he was
formed whilst being caught on by his
fans at the time was not enough to let
the message stick he needed to embark on
a journey to prove that his brand was
much more than what people had initially
assumed and so after Tyler's
announcement that he would continue to
stream he began to carve for himself
a bigger name in the streaming community
it was unlikely that anyone could have
predicted just how big Tyler would get
in the upcoming months
Tyler began by playing different games
showcasing his personality by placing
himself in different virtual scenarios
all while streaming it to a viewership
that remained in a thousand a viewership
that was filled with both new and old
faces he streamed himself playing a
range of different games from different
genres the game out last saw Tyler
explore haunted mental asylum with his
viewers with his share of scary moments
and Tyler's commentary that ran
throughout his playthrough outlast
became a fan favorite for Tyler to
stream at the time but his versatility
didn't stop there
reviewers watched as Tyler played games
like Club Penguin a children's game in
which shortly after beginning the
playthrough he began to criticize and
was eventually banned from the game due
to his use of profanity much to the
amusement of his viewers while streaming
himself playing other games
Tyler was also granted permission by
twitch to coach some of his viewers
whilst they played his favorite
character Draven in league i'ma teach
you guys I true fans at a Play dream
these streams would consist of Tyler
spectating a viewer live as they played
league whilst providing commentary
either criticizing or praising their
gameplay streaming has its own unique
advantage when it comes to creating a
personal brand especially in the case of
Tyler one when a viewer is exposed to
hours and hours of content from a single
individual it becomes easier to grow
fond of that person to those that watch
Tyler throughout his streams of which
the highlights were posted to his
youtube channel the more his audience
became attached to Tyler's personality
I had to wait I had to as Tyler
continued to open up to his audience on
stream all whilst attending University
his audience grew rapidly in early May
Tyler had reportedly reached a following
of a hundred thousand on both twitch and
YouTube later that month he revealed to
his viewers live on stream his new
website featuring various merchandise
with notable references to inside jokes
his audience would recognize but Tyler's
journey and what truly made him the
popular figure that he is today was only
at the brink of its beginning during the
summer break of 2016 Tyler began
displaying his talent to not only
entertain but also his ability to
creatively change up the content of his
stream these streams would vary from him
cooking various meals to a somewhat
questionable degree of quality to him
singing songs that would otherwise
juxtapose his tough-guy temperament
[Music]
Tyler would further reveal more size to
himself as the streams continued and as
his popularity rose in the streaming
community so too did his income in early
August 2016 Tyler officially announced
on his stream that he withdrew from
University and would now be embarking on
a new future as a full-time streamer he
had successfully found his place in the
saturated market of streaming allowing
him to earn what could only be assumed
to be a sizable income from his donators
and merchandise whether he was in his
kitchen cooking or his backyard grilling
Tyler continued to do things for his
stream that were beyond what was
expected followers on entertaining you
guys the chat the viewers he
consistently proved day in and day out
that what he should be known for was not
his toxicity from the past but as a
personality and an entertainer viewers
watched him create a bonfire whilst he
complained about his constant habit of
stuttering something they had become an
ongoing joke in his streams
I can't tell story employs I'll stutter
I stuttered too much I can't talk No
stop stuttering you've done good so far
they just stop it
stop stirring other ongoing jokes from
his stream included his favorite
McDonald's meal combination of to make
chickens and two apple pies often dubbed
by his fans as the Tyler one special his
height was another ongoing joke Tyler
would often claim himself to be six foot
five whilst his fans stated that he was
in fact five or six of which the latter
was proven to be true but Tyler never
ceased to continue the joke he had a
talent for turning many aspects of
himself things that he loved and moments
in his career into memorable
characteristics of his brand including
words like reformed or phrases like hehe
XD a phrase that Tyler would commonly
use during his toxic days in league that
quickly stuck with fans during this
period
Tyler befriended one of his fans Dimitri
Anton Otto's more commonly known on the
stream as Greek god X or simply Greek in
reference to his username on the twitch
platform the two of them had chemistry
with each other that seemed unrivaled by
any other streamer on the platform at
the time and as they streamed together
often using software like discord or
Skype to communicate Tyler would be
frequently at the forefront of attention
with Greeks voice heard in the
background as the pair either played
games together or participated in
improvised sketches with each other
these streams are still greatly
considered to be some of Tyler's best
and the time is witnessed Tyler carved
pumpkins for Halloween discusses
relationships on stream with both the
ups and downs that came with them me and
Bailey have a date next Saturday they
saw him react as his mother texted him
to say that she has made it through an
important operation Omaha texted me she
said
they saw him cook lasagna dress up as
other internet personalities paint
whilst dressed up as the TV personality
Bob Ross they saw him struggle to give a
house tour on stream they saw him
compete with his brother to create a
gingerbread house they saw him dress up
as Santa for Christmas doing a clown
show
painting eggs for Easter these moments
proved to everyone and his continuously
growing fanbase that he had changed
Tyla hood irrefutably grown his
personality brand and reputation into
something far greater than just the most
toxic player in north america by most
accounts he had changed the narrative
surrounding who he was people recognized
him phase entertainment his audience
watched to see Tyler not the games that
he played but in order for Tyler's
Redemption arc to complete there was one
stain on his brand and his story that
needed repairing his relationship with
Riot Games
[Music]
our styler continued streaming his
reputation amongst the lead community
was changing as opposed to being the
toxic player that deserved his
indefinite ban the community was
starting to see him as someone who was
changing his ways and Tyler did his best
to prove that they were right whilst off
stream Tyler would continue to play
league of legends and before riot would
eventually discover and ban the accounts
he played on he would attempt to keep
his composure and stay reformed which
meant even if things were not going his
way he would refrain from intentionally
throwing games in fact during the months
of May to early July 2017 Tyler took a
break from streaming and played league
of legends for what he claims to be 15
to 20 hours per day Tyler would often
share stories on a stream of how his
behavior has changed furthering the idea
that Tyler was indeed were formed I lost
two massive promos I did not say a
single word of Chet and as this
narrative continued to grow a movement
in the community began to grow alongside
it an official broadcast by Riot Games
for professional tournament to twitch
viewers would often flood the chat with
chants of free Tyler one bear in mind
that these broadcasts were nothing small
they would gone on hundreds of thousands
of live viewers each stream even more
notable were free Tyler one sign spotted
during the broadcasts the community
began calling for Tyler's unbanning
stating that he had changed his ways and
deserved to be brought back in many ways
despite his indefinite banning Tyler had
been contributing greatly to the League
of Legends community whether through his
coaching streams for his constant
references to the game and its community
on stream but despite all of this riot
remained fairly cold to the idea of
Tyler's return the situation was so bad
that Riot Games resorted to banning free
Tyler one signs at their events as well
as banning viewers from typing free
Tyler won in professional broadcasts the
narrative had changed Tyler who had once
been the villain of this story and
community was now seen as the hero Riot
Games on the other hand where the evil
conglomerate holding him back but
Tyler's biggest contribution to the
league community would come during the
latter half of 2017 a contribution that
was impossible for right to ignore much
long
during the months of August September
October and November of 2017 Tyler had
decided to create organize and host his
very own online League of Legends
tournament titled Tyler won Championship
Series abbreviated to simply TCS still
being banned from the game he couldn't
play in the tournament himself but some
of the participants included well-known
players from the community that were
either personalities themselves or
profession was playing in eSports teams
TCS even had a total prize pool of
$10,000 from Tyler's own pocket and the
tournament culminated in a grand final
between two teams this best-of-five
match took place on tyler one stream for
viewers to tune into for those who
hadn't seen Tyler's progression up to
this point the event would have truly
been something to behold
Tyler was once more doing something that
people didn't usually expect from
streamers on the platform the stream
wasn't anything special when it came to
production value
it featured Tyler in a shirt with cutoff
sleeves green screen effects and awkward
transitions between scenes and yet all
of these things made it all the more
enjoyable the only sponsor for the
tournament was Tyler won himself that
was all and yet this dream
single-handedly peaked over 200,000 live
viewers a number that not even some
professional league of Legends
broadcasts could match needless to say
Tyler's tournament was well received by
his fans and the Lee community it
instantly became the biggest amateur
league tournament to exist and hide the
surrounded Tyler one who'd reached to
new heights he had created a noise that
Riot Games could no longer ignore but
during these months Riot was facing PR
issues of their own on October the first
around the same time TCS was taking
place a Reddit user made a post to the
official League of Legends subreddit
that quickly climbed to front page the
post linked screenshots of messages made
by Riot employee Aaron Rutledge
otherwise known as Reyes and juror on
the official League of Legends discord
server in response to a member of the
server making a joke about there being
no point in attending professional
league event if they couldn't make a
free Tyler one sign rutledge mockingly
replies quote free Tyler one to make a
hundred K plus a year for being it
didn't gain a game he didn't make he
then continued to comment on tile
one stating quote he looks like a damn
homunculus and quote honestly it's fine
he will die from a coke overdose or
testicular cancer from all the steroids
he further went on to reveal in these
messages that he personally had to ban
several of Taiwan's accounts emphasizing
that his anger towards Tyler was
somewhat personal will had been comments
most likely intended to remain in that
discord server Rutledge had failed to
truly understand just how many fans
Tyler had built over the course of his
ban and just how many of them wanted to
see him come back to the game and just
like that Rutledge had given them their
smoking gun the original post made to
Reddit received so much attention that
it was displayed on the front page of
Reddit meaning even those with no
interested in the game or Tyler won were
able to see the post and Rutledge's
comments within hours of this post
coming to light it immediately became
clear to the league community that
Rutledge's actions were going to be met
with serious repercussions and may end
up being a historic moment for both Riot
Games and Tyler one another employee
from Riot Games commented on the post
stating quote to be very clear here what
was said is not OK and we take it
extremely seriously I'd like to
apologize on behalf of riot to both
Tyler won and the community for this we
will be taking action internally to
address this tyler responded swiftly to
the growing drama on twitter stating
quote it really sucks that some people
still hold a massive garage versus ot1
and refused to acknowledge i've changed
with that being said i have no hard
feelings towards the guy it happens with
this move Tyler had cleverly turned the
tides of the narrative between himself
and riot now it was Riot Games who were
the toxic individuals whilst Tyler was
the forgiving victim in this incident
the very next day Aron Rutledge made a
post to his Facebook wall stating quote
heads up to my friends and family I no
longer work at Riot Games please call or
text me for more details
[Music]
both tireless successful tournament and
the rutledge drama rallied a new level
of popularity for Tyler one amongst the
league community as cause to unban him
grew stronger
Tyler ones brand was established he had
shown himself to be a big part of the
league community and now the cards were
on rye aside it was their time to act
and for a while it seemed like riot
would continue to ignore Tyler leaving
his Redemption arc incomplete
Tyler himself took a break after the
grand finale of TCS leaving people
unsure of what was to come until finally
it happened on the 4th of January 2018
Tyler posted the following on his
Twitter account quote after six hundred
and thirteen days of intense rehab I am
finally unbanned from League of Legends
followed by an announcement that he will
start streaming again
the following Monday
On January of 2018
Tyler returned to twitch and League of
Legends donning what was intended to be
the costume of his favorite champion in
the game
Draven older new fans alike eagerly
awaited his return often news of his
unbanning and watched as Tyler was
finally able to play league on stream
after six hundred and thirteen days I
can finally finally play League of
Legends without getting my account bad
now even more impressive was Tyler's
view account his stream peaked at three
hundred and eighty six thousand live
viewers which at the time was a record
for any streamer on the twitch platform
Tyler had done something indisputably
impressive with his reputation and
ultimately his brand and as his dreams
continued throughout the year despite
focusing or League of Legends he would
occasionally vary things up with his
usual entertaining skits costumes and
overall antics tyler became one of the
most viewed league streamers instantly
and the community had mostly welcomed
him back with open arms and so did Riot
Games it seemed as they turned Tyler
into something even more than just a
streamer for the game in the latter half
of that year Riot Games would invite
Tyler on stage on one of their biggest
events of the year
teller was not really that much of a
personality though I respect you is
nobody the person someone that file as a
gamer as a streamer his only marketable
skills being an [ __ ]
to the dance he's gonna help us break
down this bastard not only was tireless
showcased on that broadcast but he
played a game alongside other
personalities and players live on stage
to hundreds of thousands of viewers from
a player that had once been seen as a
negative influence over their game a
player who had been brandished with the
title most toxic player in North America
a player that had received a rare
punishment by the company to someone
that would now be considered by others
in the community as the face of League
of Legends Tyler had done it he had
successfully rebranded himself through
changing the narrative surrounding his
image through creating memorable moments
for his viewers through his undeniable
will to create entertaining streams his
reputation what people were membered
about him their experience of him it had
changed when I recalled the story of
Tyler one from my teenage years of
playing league of legends myself and
first hearing about him on Reddit
watching him get banned to seeing him
change an entire community and platforms
perception of him I can't help but see
the growth in who he was and what his
brand became from a student in his
university dorm occasionally streaming a
game to his viewership of perhaps 50 or
so people to an entertainer on a stage
filled with thousands and millions more
watching from home I can't help but
think I witnessed someone execute a
rebranding of himself almost perfectly
and even as Tyler's story continues to
this day his prior history was the first
lesson I had received an understanding
that a brand isn't about the subscribers
the followers or the amount of attention
on you at any given time it's their
experience of you what they remember the
most about you but even so I always
wonder even to this day if Tyler hadn't
first been the most toxic player in
North America would any of this have
ever happened would I even be here
making this video
hello my friends and before you click
off the video just yet I do want to take
the time to say thank you so so so much
for watching to the end this project has
been the biggest I've ever done as you
can probably imagine if you've been
tuning into the channel so if you
enjoyed it do give it a like it really
does mean a lot and if you're new to the
channel welcome my name is James Chani
and I like to create documentary style
videos on business money and life in
general so if that sounds like something
you're interested in do hit the
subscribe button do hit the notification
bell because man I've got so many
amazing ideas planned and so much
awesome content on the way that cannot
wait for you all to see it I know this
video was a little bit different to the
other bits of content on my channel so
comment down below your thoughts and
I'll try and respond to it and if not I
will definitely read it for those of you
that well most of you that don't know
the channel has been growing an
incredible rate I mean the last video I
posted we were at 200 and something
subscribers and now we've hit over
200,000 it's just it's crazy I've also
set up a patreon account don't roll your
eyes essentially I love making these
videos for you all but the algorithm can
be a bit tricky and you never know I can
spend weeks on a video and it suddenly
gets too monetized and I'd love to make
this and continue to keep this as my
full-time job so if you'd like to
financially support the channel the
patreon page is probably the best way to
do so to do check it out and if you guys
want some more behind-the-scenes updates
and teasers and all of that lovely stuff
do feel free to follow me on Instagram
and Twitter that's normally the best
place to reach me there is no team I
promise you all this is just me that's
been researching scripting writing
editing all of it and you guys have made
it all the more worth it to me thank you
so much for the support as I've already
said I'm excited for all of the stuff
that is gonna be on the way Matt you
have you guys have no idea so again guys
until the next video I wish you all the
best hand to head
salut so many days this is yet to come
as opposed to being the toxic player
that deserved his indefinite ban the
community
it's many more followed by an
announcement that he will start
streaming followed by an announcement
that he was strong the narrative had
changed the narrative had changed the
narrative had changed he looks like a
damn homunculus you know okay
end of chapter 6
[Music]
when you fly
[Music]
love you